une nouvelle c'est qu'ils allaient
béatrice
[Applaudissements]
béatrice rosen et ai vu faire un
témoignage est en fait il ya eu un truc
et toutes les équipes on lit elle a un
truc alors tu sais que c'est une star
amiri maintenant oui
exactement elle est à côté de madame
paloma soient les bienvenus thaler
myriam palombes à l'om et regarder ces
quelques
belles belles belles des beaux gosses
et tu connais des gens qu'on cinéma un
petit peu
encore mais lui il a déjà passé des dark
knight
mais elle a joué dans le film est la fin
notre fine un
autre film que j'appuie 2012 paraissent
2012 d'horreur aymeric voilà
les temps grâce à la viralité
et va dire aux autres il m'a dit un
autre jeu finit mal un autre film et si
oui avec un super héros
est en fait il avait la faute à belharra
sera d'ailleurs en parlant fedaia
bertrand decker qui vient de la royauté
on sait pour la galerie et béatrice
imminent vous avez dit rooney christian
bale super avec les autres et qu'ils ont
avec john cusack avec eux mais même en
france avec des gens me disent les
américains
là comme ça je sais pas rappelé à mes
femmes et ces hommes est né en france
chine et aux états unis chine à new york
non j'adore new york
major l'état de utah
new york new york chili j'adore la big
ben
geof vous la balle ça fout de new york
mois et était née à new york si nenê
n'est pas non mais t'es pas son de new
york alors mon père est américain de new
york et ma mère est française non ils
sont convoqués comme en
mer et hôtesses de l'air c'est ouf ta
mère est tout étonné retombé à 1 étaient
passagers
par an j'ai
appris après vous êtes venu habiter
paris et après voilà et ses grandes
réparer messi ou sanghoné l'accent
américain
la qualité dans la classe d'une des
productrice de l'émission dans l'école
agata roulons
très jolie fille
nous a dit qu'il est énoncé en école
voilà et qu'elle t'a d'ouvrir mon école
ouais ouais voilà mais c'est fou et très
franchement c'est à côte et et christian
bale aujourd'hui à côté de christian
benjamin castaldi une star tu vois tu es
toujours à côté de star à l'abri à la
voile à regarder regardez-la ont tiré
sur des passants regardent la baie des
cochons
[Rires]
c'est ça les connaît
ça fait plaisir